abone ol
mı
[Müzik]
gidilecek yol temasında bu akşam Aslında
eminim ki sizler de benim gibi hani bir
büyük kentten gelince Deniz gibi
muhteşem bir kentte yaşarken birçok
sorunla karşı karşıya kalıyorsunuz
günümüzde ve küresel açıdan da birçok
sorunlar var Bizim karşımızda yüzyıldır
yaşamadığımız bir süreçten geçiyoruz
Dolayısıyla bunlara baktığımız zaman
karşımızdaki sorunların en temelde ne
olduğuna baktığımız zaman benim çok
değerli dostum fazlalığında
değerlendirmesini bizim bir Arkadaşlar
arasında topladığımız dünya konularını
Türkiye meselelerini izlediğimiz bir
düşünce havuzumuzda çalışmaları yaparken
bu üç temel Küresel sorun karşımıza
çıkıyor ilk başta küresel ısınma bugün
havaalanından buraya gel Çünkü bu
küresel ısınmanın kulaklık tehdidinin
karşımıza birçok sorunu getirmekte
olduğunun farkındayız Tabii ki içinden
geçmekte olduğumuz pandemi de değinmeden
geçmek mümkün değil Çünkü bu maskeli
yaşama alıştık hijyene Temizliğe
dezenfeksiyona çok alıştık ama
çok önemli ve nizli gibi üretim
kentlerimiz den bir olan bir bölgede
tedarik zincirinin de baskısını giderek
Her geçen gün daha fazla hissetmeye
başlıyoruz talep var satış olanağı var
fakat üretimi yapmak için yeterli
birleştirme araçlarını zamanlaması
maalesef uymuyor Lojistik soruları
karşımızda artan Lojistik maliyetleri
gibi birçok sorunla Bensiz bu akşam
görmek istemiyorum dayım Aslında sizlere
bu akşam vermek için başka bir mesaj var
Ben bu akşam
Aslında konuşmamın başlığını ekranda
gördüğünüz gibi genellikle dostlarıma bu
mesajı verirken bir sor Bu bir artı 1
kaç eder diye genellikle Herkes bir yine
oldu hindi karar Hani Kayseri diye
sormuşsunuz İki kere iki kaç eder diye
adam düşünmüş düşünmüş alırken mi
satarken bir görüntü kayıt
edebiliyorsunuz İki kere iki alırken 3
satarken 5 Ama buradaki örnekten de
görebileceğimiz gibi Ana rahmindeki
içinin tek etmesi tek vücuda [ __ ]
Dolayısıyla ana rahminden başlayan
Yaşamımızın o Karanlıklar İçinde sular
içindeki Cemil halinden doğacak bebek
olarak geldikten sonra Toprak anaya
kavuşuncaya kadar ki süreçte şu Arzu
mevcut dedikleri Dünya üzerinde yerküre
üzerindeki yaşamımızda Bizler tabiat
ananın sonsuzluğuna kavuşuncaya kadar
aslında hiçbir şeyin ölmediğini her
şeyin yaşadığına inanan bilirsek Bu
bağlamda bu düşüncelerle Hareket edersek
olaylar çok farklı olacak Burada tabi
Anadan söz açmışken meşhur şak s gelen
reklam iyi misin efsanevi siyosu Onun
bir kitabı var O kitapta da başta şöyle
koymuş anneme reklamcı olduğunu
söylemeyin O beni genelevde Piyanist
zannediyor diye bir kitap yazmış
Benimkisi de biraz o hikaye Benim şu
anda gelinlik resmini gördünüz da henüz
yüz Annem de babam da nerede olduğunu
bilmediğim bir zamanda ekranda
gördüğünüz Annem de rahmetli olduğu
zaman bundan 18'den önce beni AVM'de
zannediyordu AVM iş yaptığımı
zannediyorsun Çünkü ekşi sözlüğe
bakarsanız alışveriş bilim merkezini
konusundaki birçok şeyi bilen diye
geçiyor ama aslında benim işim
temelde b ve var olma nedenim olarak
düşündüğüm insanlar için insanlarla
çalışarak mutlu mekanlar kurgulamak ver
Dostlar dolayısıyla da bu insanlarla
çalışmada mutlu mekanların oluşturulması
hizmet ederken insanlardan oluşan
ekiplerle çalışırken buralardaki ki
öncelik benim daha ziyade bu
merkezlerinde yoğunlaşma mı sağladı
yıllarca Denizli'deki Teras Park Adana
açizane herhalde bir katkımız
dokunmuştur Dolayısıyla bu süreçte daha
sonra mutlu mekan olarak da bir butik
otelin oluşumuna da hizmet verdik
bozburun'da ve son zamanlarda
ülkemizdeki alışveriş merkezlerinin
gelişimini de gözden geçirince yaşam
beni biraz daha amca olmaya götürüyor şu
anlarda Kolektif çalışma mekanları
açısından gündelik haftalık değişik
zamanlı kısa süreli ofis ihtiyaçlarına
cevap veren bir Han oluşumu için biz
burada Aslında İpek Yolu üzerinde olan
ülkemizin Aslında biz de gelen
kültürümüzde var olan işyerlerinin
hanlarının modern versiyonu
gerçekleştirmeye çalışıyoruz işte bugün
sizlere gidilecek yolda mekan zaman ve
insana yönelik bazı duygu ve düşünce mi
kısaca aktarmak istiyorum yol bildiğiniz
gibi
yaşam boyu yürüdüğümüz Aslında yola bu
için yürümemiz gereken ve yürümekten
sonra da mutlaka hareket etmemizi
yerimizde durmamızı Telkin eden Belki de
amaç kadar kimi zaman içinde olduğumuz
yolunda önemini hep hatırlamanız gereken
bir kavram olarak yaşamımızda yürümekten
hareket ettikçe Çünkü çok daha sevdiğimi
kitap vardır peynirini Kim götürdü demek
için mutlaka o labirentin içinde ki
peyniri arayan yeni peynirleri Arayacak
olan Fareler misali bizimde berekete
erişebilmek için mutlaka hareketi
sürdürmemiz lazım bu hareketi
sağladığınız takdirde bereketi de
yakalayabileceğiniz e inanıyorum ben bu
Bereketli Topraklar üstündeki Çalışkan
İnsanların bu hareketli çabalarını
çalışmalarını sürdürdükleri takdirde o
zaman küresel sorunların dahi
aşılabileceğini ne inancımı da bu adam
bu akşam sizlerle paylaşmak istiyorum
Tabi hayatta nimetlere Ben de varmak
kadar bazen isabetli işler yapıyorsunuz
Ama bazen de insana istemedik
musibetlerle gelebiliyor ekranda
gördüğünüz fotoğraf benim iki oğlum
bundan dokuz sene evvel iki oğlumdan
soldakini genç olanı Alp'i maalesef 27
yaşındayken Bir gece ansızın Sonsuzluğa
yolculuk ve bu ekranda gördüğünüz afiş
aslında bir Efes Pilsen Galatasaray
maçında oğlum Bir önceki Sağdaki büyük
oğlum Emir Bir önceki sezon
Galatasaray'da yardımcı antrenörlük
yaptığı için basketbol takımında
Galatasaray taraftarlarının Vefa Karlı
ile Efes Pilsen bencil de oturması o
zaman Efes Pilsen da Anadolu Efes'e
dönüşmemiş daha oradaki şey için
kalplerde yaşayacaksın diye Alpin
anısına yaptıkları bir şey takdir
edersiniz ki insan evladının başına
gelebilecek herhalde en büyük acı evlat
acısı Onun için bundan daha büyük
mutsuzluk olamaz diye Ya
ben eşim büyük oğlum her birimiz kendi
yolumuzda kendi çabalarımızla bu mutlu
susuzluğun mutluluğa nasıl
dönüşebileceği için arayışlarımız da ben
bu akşam size kendi deneyimlerimden bir
ikisini paylaşmak istiyorum Sadece
dolayısıyla da buradaki Mümin sekman'ın
da ekranda size gösterdiğim kitabından
da hareket edebileceğimiz gibi Aslında
ani Balin Roma'yı teyze gelirken
filleriyle ya bir yol bul ya bir yol aç
yada Bu yoldan çekil Aslında vazgeçmek
anlamında değil sevgili dinleyiciler bu
ya da yoldan çekil Senden daha iyi
yapabilecek biri varsa artık Kenara
çekil senin dönemi bitiyorsa bırak
başkaları geçsin başkaları senin yere
daha iyisini yapsın Dolayısıyla mutlaka
yolda harekete devam etmek gerekiyor ki
bereketleri erişebilirim onun için de
benim yöntemim insanlar için insanlarla
mutlu ortamlar mutlu zamanlar mutlu
çalışma ekipleri kurgulamak şeklinde
oldu ki çalışma arkadaşlarından aldığım
de benimle hayata sarıla bildim benim
gibi acısı olan bir baba bile Eğer
yaşama böylesine sıkı sıkı sarılabilir s
Herkesin bir çaba harcaması her içine
girdim bir hamle yapması bir harekette
bulunması gerekebileceğini ifade etmek
istiyorum buradan ve dolayısıyla da
benim buradaki meteorolojimi Aslında
sevgili Cüneyt özdemir'e de buradan
Sevgilerimle Ben 5N 1K meteorolojide
bulur genellikle işlerimde hep bu 5N 1K
metodolojide gittiğimiz zaman
Buradaki en çok etkilendiğim Bundan
yıllar önce başladığı zaman neyle
başlıyordum Bu Üçleme de ne Nasıl Niçin
e giderken okuduğum bir yazardan
saymasın ekin altın daire diye geçen
Örneğin olduğu gibi önce niçin de
başlamak nedenini görerek nedenini
düşünerek nedeni için kurgulayarak o
zaman nasıl dan nevara bildiğimiz
takdirde O zaman bu 5 n 1 K nın diğer
soruları ne o nerede ve kimlerle
hayatımıza çok daha anlamlı çözümler
getiriyor ben bu meteorolojinin
genellikle çok çok iyi sonuçlar
verdiğini savunanlar da nın 5N 1K akılda
çok kalan çok çok güzel bir metodoloji
inancındayım işte bunun içinde Bu arada
konuşmamızda başında ifade ettiğim gibi
Aslında an dediğimiz zaman
görebileceğiniz gibi mekan mekanların
alanlara dönüşmesi insanların mutlu
olacağı insanların canları kadar
kıymetli paralarını harcaya bilecekleri
alanları kurgularken mutlaka hoş
zamanlar geçirebilmesi insanların
işlerinden ve evlenen atıldıkları
zamanların daha kıymetli hale
gelebilmesi sağlayacak kurgular da
Bulunduğunuz zaman o zaman imkânlarla
çoğalıyor insanlarda Pekala mutlu oluyor
işte burada dün ve yarın arada Çünkü dün
geçmişte kaldı Yarın da daha gelecek
yarın ne olacağı için üzülüyorum şuan
biliyoruz bu çok önemli ve şu anda kalma
Eğer dürtüsünü kendimiz hep beraber
doğru yapabilirsek O zaman şu an
Yürüdüğün yolda ilerlediğini takdirde
hayat bize çok daha farklı çok daha
başarılı günler gösterecek inancındayım
bütün bunları söylerken de tabii ki
mutsuzluklar biz bu olabilir Bizim için
de geçirdiğimiz kültür maalesef biraz
arabesk biraz daha fazla üzülmeyi biraz
daha efkarlanma gerektiriyor Ama eğer
biz Bu mutsuzluk yolunda ilerlemek
istemiyorsa kendimizi daha mutsuz kılmak
istemiyor isek O zaman bu mutsuzluğun
sonundaki hedefi Eğer Sizlerde kabul
buyurursanız benim yaşama nedenim de
hedefinde olduğu gibi katılmak
isterseniz yaşama Eğer bu mutsuzluğun
olumsuzluğun u atarak bir umut
ekleyebilirsiniz bu yaşamın Umut'un
abi umutla sarıla bilirsiniz Yarınların
daha iyi olacağına Ve dünden Kesinlikle
daha iyi Bugün de daha iyi olabileceğini
inanırsanız Ozan bu ve bu mutluluklara
erişmek anda kalarak ve anı yaşayarak
Pekala mutluluklara dönüşebilir sevgili
dinleyiciler Ben buradan sizlere Bu
duygu ve düşüncelerle hitap etmek
fırsatını buldum Dolayısıyla ben
yürümektense kimi zaman koşmayı da
geliyorum çünkü 148 kiloydum bir küçük
mide ameliyatı geçirmek sürekli 40 yılda
kurtulduğu zaman artık yürümek yerine
İşte bu İstanbul Maratonu günü sadece on
kilometre Tabii ki yani maratonu Henüz
daha bitiremiyorum ama Hareket bereket
Dolayısıyla Gelecek Günler için mutlaka
umutla yolumuza devam edersek çok daha
güzel çok daha parlak günlere
erişebileceğiniz de inanıyorum hepinize
sevgi ve selamlarımı sunuyorum